before we get started we want to invite
you out to our bleak Creek conversations
the week that our novel launches it's
the end of October we got this special
event planned and we want you to be
there yes we're gonna be talking about
the book answering your questions and
also premiering a very special
documentary that we shot back in Buies
Creek the location that inspired Bleak
Creek we're gonna be in Boston on
October 27th New York on October 29th
Chicago on the 30th Dallas Fort Worth on
Halloween
bring your costumes winston-salem North
Carolina on November 1st as a double
show and then we're gonna be in the LA
area at the Wilshire the Wilshire Ebell
theatre on November 3rd Sunday November
3rd and that's a very special show
because it's a local show we are
bringing out the mythical crew so you're
gonna get to see us but you're also
gonna get to see your favorite mythical
crew members including none other than
cotton candy Randy will be roaming the
grounds oh my goodness so that'll be
like a one-of-a-kind once-in-a-lifetime
sort of event there at the Bleecker E
conversation tell your la people yeah or
if you looking for an excuse to visit la
that's a good that's a good time to tack
on some some mythicality
also and just work real quick want to
remind you you get a book you get a
physic you will walk out of the bleed
Creek conversations with a physical copy
of the lost causes oblique Creek it is
included in your ticket price it's quite
a deal and just a round out the year
we've got four more dates if you want to
see us in concert again totally
different show Albuquerque New Mexico
Phoenix Arizona Sacramento California
and Valley Center California starting on
November 20th through the 23rd rhett and
Link live.com has all your information
let's do a biscuit
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the roundtable of dim
lighting we are asking the question are
you sleeping wrong was I make you feel
shameful and guilty you putting it on
them if so
mission accomplished we're also putting
it on ourselves yeah well we sleep in
rock we're gonna sleep now we're gonna
talk about our you know we talked about
sleep tight sleep right sleeping on
different sides of the bed which we have
a very specific update about that
because we had it we did it but we're
also gonna move beyond that to talk
about sleep positions and we're gonna
break out contraptions I have a
contraption an invention that I bought
didn't invent myself okay and I have
with me right here I'm gonna break it
out I'm gonna put it on I'm gonna tell
you how it feels and what I experienced
and you've had your own perils in sleep
position oh goodness
so we've got there's quite a lot to talk
about believe it or not this is gonna be
the kamasutra of sleeping episode do we
needed lots of position at Google that
you're saying positions okay sleeping
positions sleep positions there's
something I want to run by you something
that I've been experiencing and I just
need to talk it out because I don't know
what to do about it
it involves my shower and it involves my
neighbors okay all right and it involves
them at the same time you're showering
with your neighbors again as you know I
am a I'm a uh I was gonna say schedule
oriented I'm a very routine oriented
person you know is though is the word
I'm looking for
so here's the thing that I've found I
get in the shower pretty much the same
time every morning and of course when I
get in the shower as I've established in
an episode completely dedicated to my
shower routine of good mythical morning
I do the exact same thing when I get in
the shower from start to finish and I
think I may have mentioned this on that
episode but when we remodeled our
bathroom I insisted much to the chagrin
of my wife and the input we got from
people with design
which is all these people Christie are
asking ask to not put a window in my
shower so now you see where this is
going because I was like when we moved
in our house there was a little window
in the shower and you would slide it
open
it was opaque you could not see through
it is what that means so but I would
slide that puppy open and there be a
little square about the size of my head
which direction is his face facing the
front of my housing the street this yes
facing the street because the second
storey of my house is just my bedroom
it's like the back of the house has a
second storey that's nothing but my
bedroom a bathroom um walk-in closet
that's all that's up there I have a I
have a whole second level dedicated to
my bedroom life and this bathroom window
in the shower overlooks the front of the
house but the since is so offset if
you're like if you're walking down the
street or something you you would be
hard-pressed to to notice that there's a
window I I think and I would take and I
really started to enjoy at a certain
point in my shower routine opening that
window letting the steam fly out and
looking out not at the street not at my
yard but I can I can see some like some
nature there's some there's some
mountains in the distance there and I
have like a so it's like having a nice
picture of a mountain scene in my shower
do you do this while you've cut the
water off in your lathering I do it I
try to do it at multiple times you open
and close it well that was my old window
when I remodeled the house I insisted on
having a window and I insisted on
getting a bigger window because that was
only as big as my face basically I
wanted one that was like why I wanted a
wide screen view of the mountains and
everything else so I got an and I didn't
want it to be opaque so I got a full
visible window haven't you seen it
haven't you been in my bathroom no I
have nothing this you should come up
there man I don't
you're second-level I'm like your dog if
you want me up there yet to carry me
that's true I do carry Jayde up the
stairs and down I'll carry you up there
man as much as I've talked about my
toilet and now my shower it's kind of
been turned off at this point I don't
want to know about it yeah it's a lot
but I have to finish the story now okay
so yeah I've really been enjoying that
my new window is a crank window that
then it it opens this way so it turns
flat but are there so if it gets fogged
up I can open that puppy puppy out of
there the first flat and look above and
below it are you saying no there's not a
curtain in my coat on like a shower
curtain just for the window you're
telling me that you got your wife to
agree to have a see-through window in
the shower that anyone can look through
at any time not anyone I mean you have
to be in a certain vantage point to look
in that window and it turns out that
vantage point is if you're seated in
your car if my neighbor is seated in
their car in the driveway when they're
leaving to go to work and it just so
happens that every time I'm in the
shower lav it up right when I get full
lather and I look out that window I can
see there's like I can see my neighbor's
driveway I can see their car I can see
the driver's seat of one of their cars
and I can see one of them get in the car
and and put it in reverse and drive off
I think I can also see them see me but
they would be seeing you in the mirror
no they see me through the window but
they're putting it reverse are you
saying they're putting their car in
reverse and then looking over their back
window just across the street from you
no this is on the same side of the
street so when they pull in forward into
their driveway they see me okay so when
they're backing out they can see up into
your window I understand they just look
out the front windshield back at their
own house and look a little bit to the
right at my house and the second-story
back there and they can see a widescreen
window with a guy
lathered up taking a shower well because
what I was gonna say is if it was the
other situation objects a mirror are
closer than they appear you be fine
no this is direct eye to eye contact it
is a mirror involved yeah this is
objects are exactly the same size now
it's not a full week maybe disappointing
it's not a full-length window it's a
it's a landscape window because it
nipples up and it's I would say its
shoulder blades up for me six foot tall
man okay so so for Chris safe safe for
your wife you're just saying your wife's
head for Christie it's just like it
might be chin up its how like if she's
standing against the window she could
rest her chin on the windowsill does she
do that does she open the window and she
showers I don't know I don't know I need
to ask her do you still open the window
now that you can see through it yeah
because it gets fogged up and I want to
be able to see the mountains have you
heard of anti fog spray yeah I mean I
could come over and do that yeah do that
but it also lets the fog out so I don't
have to tax my my vent and I think about
things like that don't want to run my
bathroom vent too much your bathroom
vent is not for fog it's for dookie
dookie smells it's it is for fog it's
for its for steam man if it sucks the
steam out as well well yeah it also does
that so that your your mirror over your
sink doesn't get fogged up yeah I mean
it does it does that as well but I mean
you're making that much steam how hot is
your shower you taking a super hot
shower I guess yeah okay I would have
thought with the stopping and lathering
and everything you wouldn't have been
dinner that much steam and then it's get
sucked out the window but my question is
I found myself when whenever I've
started seeing the my neighbor get in
his car I've like started shimmying over
and hiding I'm hiding in my own freakin
shower that's no way to live how big is
the shower I mean it's not hard to hide
right you back away from the window I
kind of move over and I have to hunch a
little bit and it just it I'm
experiencing shame and I just don't I
don't
that's healthy what you think I need to
who is the apologetic who is the
neighbor what what what is the neighbor
the husband the wife the husband I've
seen the wife a couple of times and what
kind of relationship do you have with
the neighbour otherwise we have friendly
exchanges at the mailbox they got two
young kids that I sometimes yell at tell
him to be quiet no just kidding I'm
friendly with the kids I'm like when
they went on a vacation
they asked Christie to water their
plants okay gave us a key to our house
to do this in the case and they kept our
mail when we went on vacation okay so
okay and so that you have a friendly
neighborly relationship we never had
them over for dinner or vice-versa do
you plan on having them over for dinner
is there any is there any incentive to
do that hmm I think that it's a good
idea I'd like to say that we'd
eventually have them over for dinner
because be honest it will never happen
okay
in the case of a of a natural disaster
let's say like the big one hits the city
or something like that yeah and
everybody is kind of holed up in their
houses for an extended period of time
I'm killing and eating them yes what
kind of relationship do you want to have
with them do you want to do you want to
be the leader of your of your street do
you want to do you want to be the meat
again of your street do you want or do
you want to submit to the authority of
your neighbor well in that situation
they're both doctors but I don't think
that their leadership potential I think
they're more like they got a focus on
this is actually this is very good
information because you've got two
doctors that you need to do your bidding
in the case of a shutdown of your street
yeah you want to establish yourself as
the temporary sort of mayor of your
little area yeah because I can't be the
doctor there's already two of them all
right then you need to be making full
unapologetic eye contact with him every
morning that he backs out so okay I need
to assert my dominance yeah I just need
to I need to assert my leadership do not
back away because it will pay dividends
should I wave definitely not just mile
no just look do you know how to dominate
you know smile you don't wave if you
just stare cuz I was wondering if I
should just next time I see him by the
mailbox just bring it up listen I know
that you see me showering now let it be
your little secret that you then cash in
and when you need it you know you would
be absolutely if you do this for another
six weeks you could get this man to do
anything Wow
you're weird I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
stare him down man I'm not in my mind
my hands are gonna be up I want him to
know I'm kind of going with you here I
want her to know that I'm lathered up
and then I'm showered like I doesn't
like raise both hands I would say
shampooing sham shampooing while staring
shampooing whilst but don't look like
you're enjoying the shampoo look like
I'm shampooing but all I'm thinking
about is the power I have over you
[Laughter]
stoic leadership assertion yeah this is
not gonna be easy you know I got a
window in my shower to open it it's a
small opaque one but it doesn't open it
opens enough to like get like the
shining looking through a doorway sort
of amount of face okay so from like this
eyeball wit but my neighbors there's
only one neighbor that I could see that
way and they it's the side of their
house that they literally never go to
there's like a little walkway on the
side of the house and there's and
they're never there if I stand really
close to the nozzle of my shower and
then look back to the right over my
shoulder or turn around I can get an
angle into their house because they
remodeled after me I should say and they
put two French doors on that side of
their house where there used to be
nothing so now if they play their cards
right they can see me while in their
house but again it's still from the
shoulder from the collarbone up so I
need to try to stare at them in there
too huh yeah well you know here's
another thing here's another reason that
you need to do this because
you don't want there to be like a
Bathsheba situation with your wife oh
that's right yeah I'm saying
yeah they see her baby that's right
they're gonna put me on the front lines
of the war right you you you have to be
like I know that you can see my wife
base from the from the chin up
if King David had have known that
Bathsheba's husband could have seen her
bathe he probably wouldn't just he would
have given her some tips before he left
well listen well why don't why don't we
just assume the empowerment that that
deserved here and Christy should be
staring to she should also assert her
dominance she want to be okay sure
yeah do you think she can do that she's
saying she's comfortable doing that
trust me she's better than me it's
staring and asserting dominance okay all
right yeah I think you're basically
saying that you will be a tag-team oh
yeah yeah if that's what she wants
go for it yeah I need to ask her if she
opens I highly recommend having a window
I mean especially if there's something
to see because when you're in the shower
it's just you know look out at the at
the escape the first house that we
looked at that we actually made an offer
on before we ended up buying our our
current house one of my favorite
features of it in spite of the fact that
it needed a lot of work in order to be
habitable by my wife's standards I think
I I think we I don't know if you ever
one of their and looked at this but this
was the one that was at the very very
like last street in the inn in them in
the mountains the whole backyard it
seemed like it was teetering off the
mountain like the whole back of the
house was supported by stilts yeah and
you could see it was one of those houses
that you could just see forever and the
master bedroom had a shower that was
outside and completely covered in glass
so as like me covered but it's not
opaque glass no it was clear glass and
you would you access it from your
bathroom but it was like walking out
into like a air lock pod that was
completely glass and you can was out
there
could just see forever but you could be
seen you could be seen if someone was
down in like the other yard in a certain
place probably but I also think that it
had like curtains that could be like set
up in there and so but yeah it was but
you were pretty exposed if you wanted to
be because it was it was you know
floor-to-ceiling glass Wow and I was
super excited about you put an offer on
that house and then you basically then
they change their mind didn't want to
sell it and you you put a you raised
your price and they said you weren't a
contract right no no no no not with that
house that the dude selling that house
was not he took it off him had some
issues because he was like selling it
but not really wanting to sell it and so
even when we offered what he was asking
he didn't want to sell it it was strange
so what we low-balled initially nothing
he was insulted but that's what you got
to do you got to stare and stare him
down well if you'd a highball then you
could have been highballing from that
shower huh no I actually don't I don't
have any regrets for nothing not giving
that house though thinking about talk
about the big one that thing would have
just tumbled down the hill mayhem right
you know what come over take a shower I
don't want to take a shower in your show
come over take a shower to shower heads
I don't want widescreen window you don't
want me stir anything guy down you you
don't you don't want his allegiance is
to be divided
he's gonna leave for work one morning
xqa who is that it'll be a good test
because then it'll be like link I just
want to tell you there was a man in your
shower it's like it'll be a good test
see if you wants to come clean okay well
let's get into let's move from the
shower to the bedroom as I suggest doing
on a regular basis but first you know
what we have a very special sale because
it's my birthday week and for the whole
week of my birthday you're getting deep
discounts in mythical calm on some of my
favorite items now I got to remember
what my favorite
I listed him what about this one you're
wearing is that well yeah well primarily
the thing that I have always been most
excited about in the mythical store is
the sweatshirt that I have on right now
this is my favorite design I've made it
very clear we're bringing it back we
brought it back a couple of times
because every time we bring it back
people want it and it sells out so we're
bringing it back at a discount for my
birthday I love it I say I've made it
very clear like it's like it's the
source of contention like Oh what is
Reds favorite I just feel like I talk
about it all the time every time I wear
it but you know what selfishly you're
also getting a discount on
Rhett's beard oil that's my beard oil
Rhett's wondrously wild wooden berries
lip balm also you're getting a discount
on there's a few left of the wood grain
button-up that you know you know that
the wood theme shirt that's that's on
what you love button-up and then the the
new item the one item just because I
felt guilty just promoting all the stuff
that has my name on it or is themed
after something I like my new favorite
t-shirt in the mythical store is that
you know what time it is t-shirt it's
like you know it's got the clock running
it's kind of retro it's a nice neutral
color that almost matches my skin tone
so I can kind of disappear and seem
naked I think you'll love it you know
what time it is
tee shirt and those other items all
discounts I think up to 30% we would say
42% because that's how old I am but
that's we can't discount that much I'm
too old so up to 30% discounts on those
items for the week of my birthday
mythical calm ok so so we were answering
a question submitted to us a few a
handful episodes back that a wife sprung
on a husband that all of a sudden she
was just going to sleep on the other
side of the bed we wigged out over that
and talked about it if you haven't
listened to it you can go back and
listen to that one but basically at the
end of that we were we discussed how we
both always slept on one side of the bed
and we
we went on a rampage about is at the
left of the right side of whatever but
the long and short of it is we ended up
saying what if we switch what would
happen what would it feel like you know
we concluded I believe if my memory
serves it correctly that mixing it up in
the bedroom isn't is uh seems like a
great idea
so we should try it and then you know
days went by weeks went by and what
really wasn't motivated to do it wasn't
motivated to bring it up with Christie
order as I said and that your biscuit
just surprised her by being on her side
of the bed because I've just felt like
it can't be good but then I just started
I just started to think about all of the
listeners out there read and they're
just you know they want us to be true to
our word they want us to have
follow-through they want us to have
backbone you know if we say we're gonna
try something and we got temporarily if
not prematurely excited about it
we need to follow through you know we
don't need to be those guys who just
talk out of their butt holes and then
don't and don't really mean anything we
got to be people who put action to our
words and follow through who are some
beginnings a personal pep talk yeah
exactly
until yesterday when I was like you know
what you started talking about sleeping
in some whatever you what you're gonna
get into that I don't want to steal your
thunder and I was like well you know
what if you want to talk about that we
we can't talk about sleeping if we don't
follow throat with sleeping on the other
side of the bed so let's do it
right so we both did it last night I got
home last night and I was like I'm not
gonna do this and then I was like I
texted you like don't forget to sleep on
the other side of the bed sweet dreams
well the reason I didn't want to do it
is because I knew that it would be it
isn't like the kind of thing that your
wife is going to be like
enthusiastically receiving like it you
know I said yeah oh by the way tonight
we need to sleep on opposite sides of
the bed and she was like wow
for the podcast yeah just like do I mean
do I really have to explain this it's
like look just does just do it you said
all that to her no I mean felt that way
I was feeling that and what did she say
when you sit for the podcast well well
what she she kind of shook her head
first of all and then as we were getting
ready to go to she came into the to the
bedroom and I was already on her side of
the bed oh you did what I said I was
gonna do
wearing the contraption that I will show
you in a second and like I was like in
the zone I was I had my iPad I was
reading the book on my iPad you were
NASA you were snuggled up and she was oh
okay and and also I was you know I
didn't know okay what should I do about
charging my phone because I get over her
side of the bed and like she's got a
charging cable but like the end of the
the cable to the phone is like
completely broken off it's just like
it's just a cable that just goes to
nothing well it's different over here I
think you need to call an electrician a
idea how do you wire it directly to the
inside of the phone but she was oh yeah
that happened last night my phone
dropped off at the table and it [ __ ]
broke off the piece and then I had to
get it out of my phone what she should
be happy to get yourself oh this is so I
just well I just took my cord from my
side and used it on her side and she was
like and then we couldn't find another
cord and so then she was like I'll
discharge it in the morning now but then
last time I saw Jessie she was asking me
if she could charge her phone right she
knows needs to charge she's one of those
people and she she I said could you
please she's a 10 percent or man she I
was like could you please turn on the
noise machine because the noise machine
you didn't move that I didn't move that
no everything else is the same
the noise machine you know it's the
thing I talked about when we were
profiled by The Wall Street Journal it's
that it's like a pretty large I can't
remember the name of it it's you big to
move no I mean you got it's got a drawer
got an adapter
like in Star Wars you're like I have a
lot of things plugged in on my side and
so she'd turn it on and like I was like
it's the left left button you know but
the first thing that she said was she's
like oh because it brought about it
brought she listened to the podcasts all
about sleeping on different sides of the
bed and of course we talked about the
conversation that we had when I realized
that it wasn't the right we put her in
harm's way
I as a you know traditionally was
sleeping the furthest away from the door
and so that was putting her in between
yeah and putting her homes away and so
she was like oh I feel so safe over here
she's taunting you yeah she's I feel so
safe and also it seems like if one of
our children has an issue at night maybe
you'll be the one to go and see about it
cuz you're closer she made me feel real
bad good but I'll tell you I want to
hear how you got into it before I talk
about what my night of sleep actually
involved yeah I was like Christie
tonight's the night baby we're gonna
sleep on other sides of the bed and she
was like oh no do we have to I was like
I don't want to either
so you so that's an interesting both of
you because of the nature of your
personalities we're actually worried
that it was going to change something
fundamental about your night of sleep
yeah what whereas me and Jesse were like
all right she's gonna give me a hard
time about how close I am to the action
yeah but neither of us were worried
about it changing the quality of sleep I
had to so yeah I what we have the same
charging thing would you just put your
phone you need to get Jesse one of those
things you put that disk that you just
put your phone down oh yeah charges hey
well I have one of those on my side oh
yeah actually you got one for years it
what no and I got her one for let's say
Mother Earth Day or something and it was
Mother's Day and big her case is so
thick that it's like unreliable to use
the wireless charger
I didn't have to switch that I just got
had to make sure my water
bottle and my lip balm was on her side
so I'm a minimalist I guess I'm eats a
lot of water though it's a big bottle
minimalist it's probably not true
a man who know a man who has a liter of
water has a helm yes that's your a
maximalist so I you know I moved
everything over and um I'm getting in
the bed she's getting into bed and she's
she's doing a little reading and I'm
like I'm like oh you know I'm like wow
this it kind of feels like we're on
vacation even though we established that
even on vacation we sleep on our normal
sides of the bed that's it it did feel
like vacation to me so I kind of got
excited I was like whoa this is fresh
and your divots not as deep as my divot
that's kind of fresh to you could you
notice that yeah like we we have a look
and our mattress they have a little she
has a little divot I got a I got a
deeper divot you didn't rotate your
mattress that's true come over and do
that when you're uh when you're
showering okay checking out my window
yes all of a sudden I got excited I'm
like man this is this is me like turning
over a new leaf and then of course jade
is in the bed and she sleeps in between
us but she sleeps in a certain very
specific way she like me and Christy are
is very very routine oriented and I
noticed she was like she was not curling
up and laying down or getting under the
covers and burrowing one of her the two
options that she always does she was
just sitting there looking at me totally
confused
yeah which actually made me feel good
I'm like okay this matters this matters
to her too this is weird this is weird
so I I had to like grab her and put her
under the covers and I say okay
everything's going to be okay
we're just on the other side and that
was the extent of it like Christie
Christie apparently didn't think it was
that big of a deal because once we got
there wasn't much discussion about it I
was actually pretty sleepy so I went to
sleep now you want to talk about the
quality of sleep well before you get
into that because Barbara my experience
with Barbara was that barber tends to
sleep in between us or on the other side
of Jesse but closer to Jesse hmm like as
much as I love Barbara and Barbara loves
me I think Barbara prefers to sleep next
to Jesse and so I noticed that Barbara
was sleeping she she was sleeping on on
Jesse side which I was sleeping in that
side of the bed so like this is like it
doesn't I mean Barbara is not super
inconsistent sometimes she'll sometimes
she'll just be like next to the bed on
the floor like why are you down there
but most of times she's in the bed and
she was like kind of up against my leg
most of the night which know she was
favoring that was not a seesaw but she
but yeah but she kind of was like I
guess this is what I usually do so even
though they're in a different spot there
was a there was a confused look at first
but then I was like I'll just go to
where I usually go I'm not really gonna
think about this too much I kept waking
up in the night and here's the thing
that I noticed I think I frequently wake
up like if I change positions for I wake
up a little bit for reasons that I'll
get into when you talk about your
apparatus but the thing that I noticed
was I last night I would wake up a lot
more than how the level to which I
normally wake up so it was probably five
if I felt like five times during the
night I would I would be jostled or I
would find myself waking up and I'd have
to wake up a little bit more because I'd
be disoriented I experienced
disorientation because there's like
there's a drop-off on the wrong side
mm-hmm okay because I told the kids we
were gonna do it Lincoln
was like well if I slip on the other
side of the bed he sleeps alone but
apparently he sleeps on one side I think
he sleeps on the far side so he was like
if I slept on the other side I think I
would fall off the bed I doubt I doubt
he would but I don't know maybe he would
I've almost fallen off my bed as a
grown-ass man a few times in my current
house yeah that's like what you like for
that like something something about
rolling over and being like deep in a
dream or something
like I've I've woken up like catching
myself on my hand on the floor but I
haven't totally fallen off you need a
rail I can install a rail when I'm over
there okay
good well we need to make a list like a
little handyman list to do so I would
just wake it I would wake up more than
normal because I was trying to figure
out where I was and that happened a lot
and then so by the morning I just kind
of felt like I felt like it compromised
my my sleep what was your experience
well let me let me show you what I'm
gonna I mean for those of you who are
listening link and just describe what
this thing looks like okay so you've got
a black belt that has blue balls on it
once there's so there's how many balls
are on that thing two or three three
three there's three balls that are they
look like they like shiny like a like a
like a hand ball and they're bigger than
a tennis ball and they're they're spaced
apart they look like they can slide on
this belt the rest putting on this black
belt with blue balls on it
I hope it's called blue balls blue balls
okay he now has it on he's seating
himself back in his chair okay so I
don't I should probably know the name of
this belt but if you just go to Amazon
I'm not it's not an endorsement or a
sponsor so I'm not even gonna tell you
the name of it but if you just put sleep
I think it's called the sleep
positioning belt but it's some some some
brand
I actually started to blue ball belt so
again the that would be a better name
and the balls are hard that is there's
no give to those that's not a ball at
all it's just plastic in the shape of
Cyr
yeah well let me tell you why so the
whole idea of this thing is that it has
these no this is pretty cool
these balls each one of them if you turn
it like this it slides freely you don't
have to do that it's people can hear it
slides freely and then you can lock it
into place and it stays oh so you can
the whole idea of this thing is for
people who are trying to train
themselves to sleep in a certain
position because let's say and I think
the two positions that people train
themselves to sleep in are one on their
side so in that case you would take
these three balls and then you would
loosen them you would move them together
mm-hmm and then you would put it all in
your back so this is for people with
sleep apnea or people with snoring
problems and are there aggravating
partners that they sleep with so if you
slept on your back you'd have three
plastic hard plastic balls if they
weren't hard sonic balls into your back
now I did see a couple people on the
Amazon reviews talked about how they
ended up still sleeping on their back
and they woke up in pain kind of like
when you went skiing all day with that
thing in your shoe right now while I am
I am prone to going skiing with the
contraption in my shoe I sleeps this is
that would be for people that you might
do this you're a deep sleeper so maybe
people who are really deep sleepers
could accidentally move and still not be
woke awakened by the discomfort I on the
other hand awake immediately so but so
what I do is the way that I had it
oriented is second ago is because I'm
trying to strain myself to sleep on my
back because I currently sleep on my
side kind of in the fetal position which
by the way we'll get into this in a
second he
the most popular position not just on
your side but on your side kind of
curled up 41% of all people sleep that
way and that's the majority that's the
majority by far only 8 percent of the
population sleeps on their back that's
kind of crazy
8 percent yeah
according to sleep gorg you know okay so
so you want to sleep on your back well
well so you're moving you you let me
explain why I want to sleep in my back
but you're putting a ball on your left
tip a ball on your right hip and a ball
on your belly right so the ball and
belly button is redundant it's not a
mean I'm not gonna go all the way onto
my belly
this is so that instead of like putting
like a wedge pillow on each side of you
which is another way to train yourself I
just wear this belt in the moment that I
start to roll over to get more
comfortable because that's the way I
like to sleep I hit this ball and I
either kind of in in a light sleep kind
of just quit trying or I'll wake up and
realize that I just tried to go onto my
side mm-hmm not a real pleasant way to
sleep by the way because you keep waking
up he waking up so I've been doing this
for the past like three nights but last
night was the worst night in fact last
night at about I'd say 3 a.m. I took the
belt off oh you gave up and just got on
my side because I felt it because I was
like I need sleep I also thought that I
was gonna go to the gym my alarm was up
for like 5:50 you released the blue
balls but then I did I didn't end up
going so but let me uh this is why I'm
doing this this is not a very control I
mean for our test of switching sides of
the bed is not a really good control cuz
like you're adding this whole blue belt
situation I but I personally can safely
say that even my my experience in
sleeping closer to the door at no point
did I feel an an increased level of
anxiety it isn't like I was like oh now
I'm in the I am in harm's way it's it's
very
was a subconscious thing that I was
doing when I was choosing the side of
the bed it wasn't a conscious decision I
know and so so well in practice I
realized that my subconscious decision
was unnecessary like I did you weren't
oriented by having the drop off on the
wrong side no cuz like I said I sleep on
both sides of the bed on vacation I
don't we don't have a side of the bed on
vacation okay and I've also slept on the
right side of the bed the left side of
the bed like I slept on the left side of
the bed in my last house now I sleep on
the right side of the bed because the
door okay yeah I remember but last night
you're saying that you had the worst
night's sleep you've had since starting
to wear the blue belt so that tells me
that it it could have been a contributor
I can't tell you that it was it I can't
tell you that it wasn't but I would but
to me it was I had an anxiety about
getting this is the first night that
I've done it where I had to I was
thinking about getting up and going to
the gym and I just I don't know it just
translated into you're not getting good
sleep you're not gonna go to sleep
you're gonna be tired you're you're not
you need to get on your bat you need to
get on your side so you can actually
good that was the kind of anxiety yeah
but if I if I know that if I need to
work myself up to get some gumption to
go to the gym and I set my alarm
sometimes I'll wake up like two hours
beforehand and then one hour beforehand
something subconsciously it kind of keys
me up so as if I were gonna miss my
alarm or like not actually go but I
ain't wearing those balls well maybe you
need to be okay so so you wanted to
sleep on your back the reason I wanted
to sleep in my back is because most of
this most of the science shows that it
is the healthiest position for your back
your shoulders and your hips and I have
issues of varying degrees with all three
of those things right so straight from
sleep org I'm just going to read it
though it's not the most popular
position only 8% of people sleep on
their backs it's still the best by far
the healthiest option for most people
sleeping on your back allows your head
neck and spine to rest in a neutral
position this means that
there's no extra pressure on those areas
so you're less likely to experience pain
sleeping facing the ceiling office is
also ideal for warding off acid reflux
which is something I've had a little bit
of problem with - just be sure to use a
pillow that elevates and supports your
head enough you want your stomach to be
below your esophagus to prevent food or
acid from coming up your digestive tract
however snoozing on your back can cause
the tongue to block the breathing tube
making it dangerous position for those
who suffer from sleep apnea a condition
that causes periods of breathlessness ah
this position can also make snoring more
severe now a lot of people have also
said this better for wrinkles not that
that's necessarily a motivation for me
but hey hey ami I want to be as long as
I want to be as long it's jung as long
as I can you sleep on your back helps
with wrinkles it seems like it would it
stretches your face well Oh on your side
it's mush ease your face here's this
position on your side where your torso
and legs are relatively straight as
opposed to the fetal position also helps
reduce acid reflux and since your spine
is elongated it Ward's off back and neck
pain plus you're less likely to snore in
this news posture because it keeps
Airways open for that reason it's also
the best choice for those with sleep
apnea 15% of adults choose to sleep on
their side but there's one downside it
can lead to wrinkles because half of
your face pushes against a pillow and
then you're up to the 41 percent of
adults which is the fetal position it's
the most popular sleep position a loose
fetal position where you're on your side
and your torso is hunched and your knees
are bent especially on your left side is
great if you're pregnant I think it has
something to do with what organs are on
what side and where the baby is and what
it's pressing on and that's why this you
should be on your left side that's
because it improves circulation in your
body and in the fetus and it prevents
your uterus from pressing against your
liver oh yeah that should have read
ahead prevents your uterus from pressing
against your liver which is on your
right side this pose is also good for
snores but resting in a pedo position
that's curled up too tightly can
restrict breathing in your diaphragm and
it can leave you feeling a bit sore in
the morning particularly if you have
arthritis in your joints or back which I
have both of those things
prevent these woes by straightening out
and straightening out your body as much
as you can instead of tucking your chin
into your chest and pulling your knees
up high you can also reduce strain on
your hips by placing a pillow
between your knees and of course the
most unpopular and final position is
sleeping on your stomach which is what
my dad does well this is good for easing
snoring it's bad for practically
everything else seven percent of adults
pick this pose but it can lead to back
and neck pain since it's hard to keep
your spine in a neutral position plus
stomach sleepers put pressure on their
muscles and joints possibly leading to
numbness tingling aches and irritated
nerves oh yeah so if I mean I have this
long-standing experience of waking up
all my stomach and I would I will have
been sleeping on my arm and then I'll
wake up and I cannot feel it yeah and
like I'll shake it and it's it would be
so bad it won't even have the tingles
and you think oh no I've done it it's
gonna have to be amputated
yeah which we wrote about in that song
have you ever
[Music]
I will grab my arm my dead arm with my
live hand on the other arm and put my
finger up to my mouth and bite it I've
done that just to see if I could even
feel biting my own finger and it would
just be a very numb burning sensation
and there have been a few times when
I've woken up and I both of my arms are
completely dead like I've I was sleeping
on both of them never happen talk about
a weird position a weird sensation man
you're waking up and you just got your
floppy at the shoulders like that is
scary and you know when you you shake to
try to get them to wake back up like if
your foot falls asleep it's a lot worse
if it's from your like shoulder all the
way down it hurts yeah as the blood
comes back you had to get the life to
come back in it and going I don't have
that problem anymore because I I just I
very very rarely make it to my stomach
because of the problems that I've had
with my shoulders right but um but you
find sleeping on your side or what do
you normally sleep on your you start off
on your back on my back
are you stay on your back usually yeah
now I'm very broad-shouldered you know
so it's like for me to sleep on my side
it's like my shoulders have to collapse
on themselves because it's it's it's the
woods like it just feels unusually wide
like right here you see that mm-hmm
the broadness just like it wants to
collapse on itself when I'm on my side
but the problem that I had I I think
I've told this story a number of years
back I started to get extreme pain and
like inside of my shoulder and the
doctor and the physical therapist ended
up saying well they're like how do you
sleep and I was like I sleep on my right
side spooning my wife with my right arm
used as a pillow with my elbow bent so
it's like my bicep is against my right
ear and then my hand is behind my neck
you know and sometimes I'll put my hand
up and I'll grab the the the head of the
bed and just hold on and like just in
case what someday and I had this routine
for a long time with a bridge as I was
going to sleep I would tap a little song
on the on the head of the bed so that
wasn't annoying do you know what else
that would and it would like put me to
sleep I know I'm weird Christy never
once asked me why are you tapping this
is like she had already live with me so
long she's like I'm not even gonna ask
she quit asking why a long time ago 18
months in other than why did I do this
why does this continue and I started the
physical therapist said that I ground
down my bones started grinding against
each other because they were constantly
in like in this grinding fashion like
here at the tip of my my collarbone and
my shoulder blade and they said it was
irreparable damage and that really
rocked my world they say you need you
can't sleep on your side and it was
hurting so bad I could no longer do it
and some and so I would stop I started
sleeping on my back and and then if I
rolled over did you train yourself to do
that if I rolled over on my side it
would hurt and then if I rolled over on
the other side it wouldn't hurt but I
would I was so afraid of doing the same
thing to the other shoulder that
subconsciously I would wake up whenever
I'd roll on my side like I would wake
myself up so it was like I had blue
balls in my brain yeah waking that would
wake me up you can relate it up so
that's I don't need I don't need your
belt I got it in my brain so now I'll
wake up I'll wake up on my side
sometimes I wake up throughout the night
trying to sleep on my side now go back
to my back so and last night I woke up
further because once I started to wake
up I'm like where the hell am I whose
lamp is this I'm in the same bed has it
drop off over here I
I don't know I haven't given up on this
but last night was unpleasant and I can
one of the things I concluded as I was
like you know when I sleep on my side
now first of all I favor my left side
and the reason I've I actually I favor
the side that faces away from my wife
and let me explain why again I have this
I have a very high self-preservation
instincts and you know my wife talked
about this before that usually large
people have learned how to like me have
learned how to not hit people I don't
step on people I don't accidentally
elbow people you can hang out with me
for an extended period of time and I'm
never going to accidentally hurt you
with anything
my wife is small so she steps on
people's feet she also gets
uncomfortably because the stakes are low
is that what you're saying yeah she also
gets uncomfortably close and at times
has hit me my accident would like an
elbow or something but I just it gets
close enough on a regular basis if she's
like if I'm really close to her and
she's moving or something I don't like
to get hit in the face as a general rule
yeah so it's not a good type consciously
face away from her which seems less
romantic and I think she interprets it
as less romantic but it's really just to
protect myself so I noticed last night
once I took the blue balls off and I
went to my side I was facing always on
my right side but I also realized that
right side meaning you were still facing
away from her facing away okay yeah now
you're not favoring the side you're just
you're protecting yourself but I do
especially fear especially if we have a
California king size bed which
California king is actually four inches
narrower than four inches longer so a
king size bed is 80 by 80 I went with
the California king which is 84 inches
long not like I needed those extra four
inches but I'm a big man and so I was
willing to sacrifice the four inches of
width so that's 76 now what the
does what that means is that we still
have a lot of space and if she's kind of
in her position and she hasn't migrated
I will naturally sort of sleep on my
right side but throughout the night I
will probably flip sides cuz you get
it's the same reason that people who are
incapacitated in bed they have to move
them because you get bedsores even over
the course of a night if you don't move
certain things will start hurting a
little bit so what I noticed last night
is that because I'm they're restricted
and I can't move I'm actually starting
to get stiff even my back which I'm
supposedly in a healthier position I
feel like in fact my back is a little
bit stiff today after having slept on my
back and maybe it's because I didn't
have the right pillow and maybe I should
have liked it wasn't until I halfway
through the night that I started
supporting my knees and like getting my
legs up a little bit
I just don't know it feels restrictive I
think you just need Jesse to kick you in
the back throughout the night yeah that
could help but I also prefer sleeping on
my side because I often find myself in
beds that are not long enough like if we
go on tour I can't lay on my back in
that bunk bed I'm too big
there's too much Rhett to lay on your
back unless I have my knees bent which
you can't sleep with your knees bent on
your back
and so I sleep in the feet of literature
like a toddler I sleep from the fetal
position to fit in those bunks many
hotels you go to or if you go to air B&B
if they don't if they have a cook if
they have a regular-sized bed I'm
probably going to be going off of it you
got a tough life man
so I I like to I I sleep on my side so I
just don't know if I should train my
brain like the problem with getting the
blue balls into my brain is that then I
will be trained to sleep on my back and
then I'll be trying to do that in all my
circumstances and I actually think it's
going to be a problem in others and when
I'm gonna have to get out of my routine
of sleeping in my big bed so I don't
know what to do with these blue balls
well second choice is straddle a pillow
put a pillow between your knees that
still helps with your back right yeah
well
yeah that's hips if no I think it helps
with both it it feels like yes sleeping
on my side but keeping my legs straight
and not doing the fetal position I mean
my back is doing fine it's not like I'm
experiencing back problems that are so
debilitating that I'm trying to sleep
it's just like you know what I'm getting
older I already have a predisposition to
back problems I've got a little hip
thing kind of like the same kind of hip
thing that you do or like feels like
it's getting caught I have a shoulder
thing as well falling apart and so it's
like maybe I should go ahead and in
preempt this but I just don't know what
I'm gonna do I feel like I'm on a
crossroads I'm a crossroads but I'm
wearing a belt that's got blue balls on
it I think you need to sleep on your
back and not worry about the travel and
the restrictions of other places that
such the minority of how you sleep do
you think I'll just naturally adjust in
those situations yeah yeah don't let the
tail wag the dog of the of your back now
I've punched Christie in the face while
sleeping multiple times and there's many
times that I wake up where I go to my
right side and I put that elbow up
because I still have that long standing
and then I'll but before I can correct
myself which I always do she's she's
like fleen so if she were here she'd be
chiming in and saying like I don't sleep
good because I've been punched and I've
been elbowed a lot and sometimes laughed
at what does she move because I and she
laughing she tolerated this in a literal
double bed for the majority for like the
over 15 years of your marriage she your
wife needs like some sort of medal Hey
there should be some kind of like last
medal she's lasted with the lane she
should have some sort of like you know
that's what i'ma get her for you talk
about Mother's Day maybe Christmas imma
get her you've lasted with link there
should be an anniversary there's some
kind of like service for people who've
been through hard things I'm not good at
consoling someone I've punched when I'm
asleep and I'm just like I'm kind of
groggy
I'm sorry I hit you in the face won't
happen again tonight I try so that yeah
there's a lot of like I'll wake up with
her hand pushing on my elbow it's just
like you know like some people have to
roll over their snoring partner like
kind of log roll she has to like push
her the elbow away so apparently I'm not
on my back the entire time oh yeah I'm
moving around a lot I like yeah I don't
but when he plexiglas well I watched a
movie one time and it was about an Amish
family and I don't know exactly why they
did this but they had to put the boy and
the girl in the same bedroom it's not a
documentary of this movie and they put a
board in between them there's like a bed
board so I went a man and a woman a boy
and a girl needed to sleep in the same
bed but they didn't wanted to mess with
each other well they're not siblings I
know they weren't siblings it was like
oh your cousin from so-and-so is coming
into town he's got to sleep in this bed
so we're gonna put this board up okay
but then those hands reached across that
board oh yeah it was it wasn't that kind
of movie but it would you I think it
just Illustrated that you know you can't
you can't stop the lustful intentions of
teenagers with a piece of wood no pun
intended I mean a we are we slowly
creeping towards the old married couples
sleeping in separate beds like my my
grandparents slept on like my mom's
parents they slept on opposite in twin
beds on opposite sides of the room well
I could get into a lot of trouble by
giving my actual thoughts on this do it
we this will never happen in my house I
don't think because the idea of sleeping
in separate beds is like so
quintessentially unromantic in my wife's
view now I think first of all what if
you made it technologically cool like
it's two twin beds that are they they're
smushed together and then you know you
push a button and they they go on tracks
to like opposite sides that seems like
overkill because you don't need more
than one bed it's a like one you don't
need a super wide bed to make a love I
don't know how you make love but
typically I'm taking up the amount of
space that one person takes up I use all
available really but you know but what
I'm saying is that typically you have to
be in physical contact with each other
so you're only taking up so much space
you don't need I don't I might use all
four corners of the California king-size
bed but it's just because it's there to
be used if the bed was cut in half
I could there's still four corners
there's a lot to do and I don't think
like I feel like the the thought is if
you sleep in a separate bed or even in a
separate room like Jesse's grandmother
did for a long time for as long as I
ever knew gaga and in Papa they were in
separate rooms
I bet that was snoring related yeah it
probably was I don't think it
necessarily okay I could see how being
in separate rooms would be a problem
and I could see how you could think that
being in separate beds would lead to
less overall physical contact and
therefore less you know intimacy maybe
that's true I don't think that it that
would be the case I don't think it would
be the case either cuz I don't it
doesn't happen by accident
it's not like you roll over and like
whoops right look what's happening yeah
and so because of that I feel it's not
gonna happen
and I've sleep fine but I do you know
I'm such a light sleeper that you know
if my wife wakes up to go to the gym I
wake up I there's no there's no world in
which I don't wake up and even with the
noisemaker never going
even if I put a sleep mask on I had this
just like sensitivity to being I'd be a
good like Watchmen so what I'm saying so
in conclusion what are you gonna do you
gonna stick with the balls man give it
give it a give it another week yeah I
feel like I gotta try it for a little
bit longer sleep on your back you got to
do it get your own bed I feel like I
just got all the way I'm gonna go to the
point where I'm without the balls able
to sleep on my back and see if that if I
if there's a noticed improvement in like
joint health I am NOT however gonna
sleep on Chrissy's side of the bed
anymore been there done that I did it
for you
I didn't learn that much but it's over
Jesse said did say I could get used to
this when she when should we did it last
night but I doubt that she'll be on my
side of the bed when I get home tonight
right cuz why
yeah there's books to move there's books
to move there's there's chargers that
Shinae go yeah I mean there's drawers
our drawers are so different let's have
a wreck you're gonna recommend something
yeah I am
I'm going to recommend a television show
that is for a specific sense of humor I
showed it to you and made you watch two
episodes it's I think you should leave
with Tim Robinson it's a sketch show on
Netflix I think you should leave and it
is so dumb it is just such a dumb show
and that's why I like it to make you
feel smart no it's not dumb and like
trashy reality TV I'm saying that like
it it's just stupid comedy you know it's
just taking and well in in a sense it's
smart and the way that they do it but
it's just like a large percentage of the
population we watch it and be like this
is
just too stupid this is just too crazy
for my sensibility but I very rarely
encounter something that's too stupid
for me so I highly recommend it and the
short episodes are like 15 minutes long
apparently this guy was a he was a
writer and maybe a very very short live
cast member on SNL I think he's kind of
from that world but it is and there's a
bunch of like you know noticeable
recognizable celebrity comedian cameos
in it and it's just really really stupid
go for it I actually think we should
leave
hashtag ear biscuits let us know what
you think where did you sleep and why
you rolling around
did you try will you accept the
challenge and let us know sleeping on
the other side of the bed and if you
need a set of hash tag your biscuit if
you need a set of blue balls depending
on how my experiment goes I might be
selling some on Craigslist we'll talk at
you next week hashtag blue balls to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]